hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll many times here on mindscape
we've had issues that dealt with
philosophy right either explicitly about
philosophy or talking about biology or
physics or politics in a way that
involved philosophy but almost always
the kinds of philosophy that we talked
about were based on the western
tradition of philosophy the tradition
that goes back to the ancient greeks
socrates plato aristotle people like
that we all know that's not the only
tradition out there
it is the tradition that i know the most
about for better for worse so it's
harder for me to lead an intelligent
conversation about other areas but for a
long time i thought that we should have
a good conversation about eastern
philosophy chinese philosophy in
particular there was a very very active
set of schools of philosophy in ancient
china about the same time as aristotle
and his friends were inventing greek
philosophy the warring states period in
particular was a period where you were
inventing new ideas in confucianism
taoism and other kinds of traditions so
obviously these are huge topics much too
much to talk about in one podcast in any
comprehensive way but we're going to try
to do it anyway today's guest is edward
slingerland who is a distinguished
university scholar and professor of
philosophy at the university of british
columbia so he's an expert in ancient
chinese philosophy he's translated
confucius the whole bit but one of the
reasons why he's interesting to talk to
is because he doesn't simply talk about
that ancient philosophy for its own sake
he relates it to modern ideas he tries
to make the point that it is still a
vibrant kind of set of ideas that
relates in interesting ways to our
current predicament as human beings and
our current knowledge as scientists
learning more about how we think how we
act in the world in fact his most recent
book is called drunk as in you've had a
lot to drink you are now drunk the
subtitle is how we sipped danced and
stumbled our way to civilization
so as i asked him maybe i shouldn't give
it away no i probably will as i ask him
in the podcast what does that have to do
with ancient chinese philosophy well the
answer lies in this idea that is in the
title of the podcast episode of oo
which is translated in various ways as
either in action you know not doing
anything but perhaps more accurately as
effortless action
as doing things in a way where you're
not overly overthinking it right when
you're in the zone when you're in that
flow state rather than being a little
bit too cognitive about what goes on
that was a central preoccupation of both
confucianism and taoism and other
schools of ancient chinese thought it
has a lot of resonance with modern ideas
about meditation neuroscience etc and
the reason that edward got into the
history of alcohol and tipsiness was
because this is a sort of artificial way
to get to that not caring too much zone
not being in too cognitive of a state to
engage
now the ancient chinese philosophers
were a little bit more systematic they
didn't say just go out there and get
drunk they offered some advice for how
to live better basically and i think
that's one of the major differences
between ancient greek philosophy and
ancient chinese philosophy there's a lot
of overlap they talk about very similar
subjects both are abstract and often
logical but the emphases are a little
bit different and the greeks may be
emphasized a little bit more system
building and that the chinese emphasized
a little bit more down-to-earth
practicality how to get this done kind
of stuff their philosophy was meant for
people and how people live their lives
so we're going to learn about that it's
a lot to handle obviously i apologize
for anyone out there who actually knows
something about chinese philosophy will
have a very superficial treatment but
it's very educational for people like me
who want to know and know almost nothing
that's the kind of thing that we're here
to do at the mindscape podcast so let's
go
[Music]
edward slingerland welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks for having me
now i have to start uh by apologizing
for not being the world's best podcast
host you have a new book out uh called
drunk about alcohol and its historical
cultural history and things like that so
the typical thing would be for me to
invite you on the podcast to talk about
that yet i'm not doing that because
for a while now i really wanted to talk
more about ancient chinese philosophy uh
because we already had shadi barch on
the show talking about how chinese
people read ancient greek philosophy
plato and aristotle and so forth but we
haven't really talked about the the
chinese philosophy i know you're an
expert in that but i thought that just
to start
i mean i want to know how it all fits
together you've written a book about
alcohol you've written scholarly work
about ancient chinese philosophy you
also have a web project on comparative
religions and you've been involved in
modern psychology and neuroscience and
so forth do you think that all this work
sort of falls an under umbrella does it
have a theme or is it just what you
happen to think is interesting at the
time
it all fits together if you squint
and look at it from far enough away so
there's a strange connection between
my early chinese philosophy work and the
latest book on alcohol
so
what i'm one of the themes that i'm
interested in in early china is this
idea of way
or effortless action okay so i argue
this is going all way back to my
dissertation
i argued that if you look at
these other otherwise disparate
appearing confusions in taoists and
early china
what they all have in common is they
want to get you into the spiritual state
that's called
which literally means no doing or no
trying no striving but i translate it as
effortless action
it's a state where you you lose a sense
of yourself as an agent
you lose a sense of time
um it's a lot like you know it's like
being in the zone
and i talk about parallels with chicks
uh mihai chiksumi hai's idea flow it's
not dissimilar from flow
they think if you can get into this
state
everything's gonna work out you will
solve problems you'll be creative uh
people will like you so you get this if
you get into a way you get this power
that comes with it that unfortunately in
modern mandarin it's pronounced duh
comber simpson exactly
let me let me always love this since
this is an audio podcast in english uh
and we're gonna be using a lot of
ancient chinese words uh maybe when
possible let's spell them just so people
can yeah so these are these are the only
two chinese terms i think we'll need to
know so ooway is w-u-w-e-i
okay
and then duh is just d-e
good so this is it's sometimes
translated as virtue with a capital v
i prefer something like
charismatic virtue or charismatic power
okay it's uh when you when you get into
a state of way
they have a the early chinese have a
theological explanation for why these
two things hold together so they think
you get into uwa you're following oh
sorry one the other term you're
following the dao
right so uh used to be spelled tao with
wade giles romanization now we spell it
dao using pinyon but same word
you're in harmony with the dao heaven
this kind of supernatural agent
likes you you're doing what heaven wants
and so heaven gives you this power
that allows you to be successful so if
you're a confucian
it's the power that makes people want to
obey and follow you
even without being forced they just
admire you and they flock from all over
to follow you
if you're a taoist it's what allows you
to move through the world skillfully you
yeah you relax people around you you
help them
uh just the
your presence makes them relax and they
become more in
in the dow and so you kind of uh you
give other people little bits of your
duh in this contagious way that's
interesting
so um
i got interested in this
just from a historical perspective so in
my dissertation i argued that
the
the centrality of this
metaphor the state metaphorical state
can explain lots of other things that
early chinese thought uh so the the
central they face attention they have
this they want you to get into a state
of spontaneity
they want you to be relaxed and to not
try
but how do you consciously
try to not try yeah how can you
consciously try to be spontaneous
when you know that that's the key to
success so you're in a situation where
you know you have to relax and how do
you try to do that
and so i argued in my dissertation and
then later in my first academic book on
this topic that uh i call this the
paradox of way
how do you try not to try
it's a direct paradox you can't it is a
genuine paradox you can't solve it later
on when i wrote a trade book about this
so my first trade book's called try not
to try
i just i point out how just cognitively
it's a paradox because you're
you're activating the part of your brain
that you're trying to shut down when
you're trying not to try it's a lot like
the the paradox dan wagner the late dan
wagner talked about with a
don't think of a white bear right if i
say that to you you think i've activated
the concept right uh i have to i have to
tell you to share this wonderful story
you told in your ted talk about mind
ball
oh yes of mine ball yeah so this is i
love this game because it it takes that
tension
and boils it down to just the the
smallest space possible so you know mine
ball is as you two ends of a table
you've got this metal ball in between
you
and the goal is to push the metal ball
to the other end of the table and it
falls in some hole and when it does that
you win
but of course the trick is you're
pushing it with your mind
and you're hooked up to so the way it
works is you're hooked up to eeg monitor
and it's measuring alpha and theta waves
so that's the the signature your brain
kicks off when you're relaxed when
you're you're not trying
and the more the way the game is set up
the more alpha and theta waves you
produce the more force you exert on the
ball
so the way to win at mind ball is to not
try to win that's genius and it's it's
genius it's a per and it's a perfect uh
microcosm of this tension right and the
the first time i played it i was like oh
i do i'm a professor of chinese
philosophy i'm going to be great at this
um and i played against the
neuroscientists who ran the exhibit
and she kicked my ass
she was so good at it it's funny because
i started out um
i had my eyes closed and i could hear
you could hear the ball moving around so
you know something's happening
and i opened my eyes and i was winning
so the ball was mostly down to the other
end of the table
and i thought oh i'm winning i am pretty
good at this as soon as i thought that
it started rolling back toward me and
then i started panicking and i was like
yeah way way relaxed and it just didn't
it didn't work um and she said she just
developed tricks to win at this game so
she would just as soon as the game
started she would think about her
favorite vacation on this beach and
remembering what it was like to lie in
the sand
um but this is a great you know it was
and it's so what i argue in the trade
book actually is this is a attention we
face in our lives all the time
where um
you're on a first date and you know that
to make a good impression you should be
charming and relaxed and you know feel
confident
but how do you
do that if you're not feeling that way
yeah um and then professional athletes
and performers know that they perform at
their best when they're relaxed in the
zone
and they live in constant fear of
choking right they live in constant fear
of that feeling i had when the ball
started rolling back toward me and i was
like oh i'm not a new way i got to get
back in a way
so this is a it's a real tension and
what the early chinese do is come up
with various techniques for kind of
doing an end run around the tension
so
you know meditate sit like this and
count your breaths
um
do rituals so the confusions give you
rituals to do and the idea is that the
repetition of that you'll start to
internalize certain values and they'll
become spontaneous eventually
so there's a lot of different ways they
develop to get around the tension that i
think are helpful
but in one of these texts that the
juan's one of these early taoist texts
so z is in current opinion it's a z h u
a n g zi zhuangzu
um little known dallas everyone knows
about laozi and the dao da jing but
juan's was much more interesting um
at one point compares the taoist sage to
a drunken person
so he tells a story about someone's
going home from a party they're really
drunk they're riding on a cart
and they fall off
and yet they're not hurt they just kind
of roll with it
and he says you know they didn't know
that they were riding they don't know
that they've fallen out
their spirit was whole
and it's clear at the end he he's using
this as a metaphor he says if you can
make your spirit whole in this way
by means of of wine how much more so can
you do it with heaven because he wants
you to be drunk on heaven he wants you
to be drunk on the spiritual force
but that made me
that analogy made me start thinking
about alcohol as a cultural technology
so
what if it's the case that cultures
cultures are aware that there's this
tension that spontaneity or being open
is key to attaining certain goals that
are important for the culture
and it's hard to consciously make
yourself spontaneous so maybe one way
around the tension is to use this
chemical substance to short circuit the
paradox you instead of trying with your
mind to shut down your mind you're
taking a chemical and turn down your
prefrontal cortex a few notches
so that's what got me interested in
alcohol as so i'm interested in
spontaneity and trust
that's an overarching theme that uh has
to do with why i got interested in
chinese philosophy in the first place
and alcohol actually is not as wild to
departure from that as it might seem oh
yeah suddenly it makes perfect sense and
it fits in with a lot of themes we've
talked about on the podcast in other
episodes about conscious versus
unconscious thought right system one
versus system two cognitive things and
and making certain processes
more unconscious is often a success
strategy right if you have to think
about it too much you're gonna fail
yeah and so that's what's distinctive
about early chinese philosophy that
appealed to me
uh is that they it's if you want to
think of it this way they're a system
one
ethics they're they're virtue ethicists
and virtue ethics roughly is this idea
that
the way to get virtue ethics roughly is
a system one ethics as opposed to
the dominant enlightenment models which
are totally dependent on system two
so the dominant models of ethics in the
west are deontology and utilitarianism
and what they have in common is they're
both cognitive control
system two models so and if you're kant
you what's the right thing to do
you stop
you apply the categorical imperative
and that tells you what the right thing
to do and then you force yourself to do
it
top-down
cognitive control
if you're a utilitarian what's the right
thing to do you stop you measure the
values of the different options you do
the math and then you force yourself to
do the one that maximizes payoff yeah
so again a system two cognitive control
basis the step in which you do the math
is not very system one it's not very
unconscious yeah
yeah it's it's that's that's one of the
central flaws i would argue with the
utilitarian the idea that there's some
kind of metric that's universal to
values i think is absurd
and i think yeah what you would point
out is that that that step of assigning
value
is a fully system one thing and that's
that's where it's not utilitarianism
isn't what utilitarians think it is um
but so as opposed to those two virtue
ethics is the idea that uh
the way you determine what the right
thing to do is is spontaneously
know
what the right thing to do is the
virtuous person
in
in a situation that calls for a given
virtue
will just know how to do it and when and
when virtues are in tension so let's say
fairness is in tension with empathy
uh they'll know how to negotiate that
tension intuitively because they've
they've internalized these virtues and
norms
and they can do it in a way fashion
basically they do it in the spontaneous
way
i've loved sharing all that i've learned
and taught at the great courses plus
over the years and i've heard fantastic
feedback from many of the listeners
who've signed up too now the great
courses plus has become wondriam that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
everything you loved about the streaming
service and so much more i recommend for
example checking out understanding
economics game theory this is one of the
one dream courses that help you
understand game theory which is
something we've talked about here on the
podcast and are going to talk about more
in the future it's a story of economics
and mathematics and decision making that
is relevant to business politics
relationships and more but that's not
all one dream has thousands of hours of
fascinating mind-blowing video and audio
content to explore i know you're going
to love wondering as much as i do use
the special urls they know we sent you
from here go to onerium.com
mindscape for a limited time sign up and
you get a free month trial of unlimited
access that's w-o-n-d-r
dot com slash mindscape again one dream
dot com slash mindscape
so i have a very silly version of this
that you know might resonate with some
listeners or even you which is the
progressive rock version of this
bill brewford who's a famous drummer uh
for yes one of the great progressive
rock groups and eventually quit and
joined king crimson instead and the
reason why he gave was literally that
uh when he was in yes like it was great
you know he was having a good time but
it was just everything was planned and
they would hyper
figure out like what note should be in
what key during what part of the solo
and right be told what to do and he said
he went to king crimson and just you
play you're just supposed to know what
to play and there are no instructions
given and that's very much like the sort
of because a lot of the progressive rock
musicians were classically trained it's
very much the classical music music
versus jazz music sort of uh ethos in
some sense
right right but you know the jazz so i
talk about jazz and and try not to try
you are just kind of playing what you
want to play but if you're not trained
if you're not trained that thing you're
going to play is stupid
right it's gonna sound terrible so the
only way you can
solo
my my
uh former brother-in-law is a jazz
pianist in rome oh okay and he you know
he plays very experimental jazz and it's
all about soloing and improv
but he practices like several hours a
day you know
and
his ability to improv
is completely dependent on his classical
training and and all of the work he's
put into it so
you know it's
jazz values that spontaneity but it's
because in some ways it's hiding all the
work that went into the getting there
well yeah that is a an issue that came
up with me whenever i sort of um come
into contact with taoism in particular
but maybe also other kinds of chinese
philosophy so i want to dig into that
but but uh we've already talked about
several of the schools of thought etc i
mean let's let's give the road map to
our listeners like uh if is it
okay to think of confucianism and taoism
as like the two polls of this or is it
more complicated than that where did it
all start all those things two minutes
you got it
yeah two minutes
all over chinese philosophy in two
minutes yeah uh there's there's several
schools i study the whirring states
period right so my specialty is you know
roughly
fifth through 3rd century bce
and this is the golden age of chinese
philosophy it's when all the native
schools kind of got going and
um and then when china gets unified i
lose interest it gets really boring it's
really boring after that um
but this is an exciting period so the
the players are roughly
uh the confucians so there's confucius
the supposed founder we just have record
of his teachings
um and
and very roughly speaking we can say
they're the school of trying
so they think that the way you get to
uwa
is by training they think that you're
incomplete by nature
and what you need is cultural training
and so they have these very elaborate
rituals
they have classical learning so you have
to memorize these classical texts and
the idea is that these
there there was this perfect for
confucius there was this perfect culture
the western joe that was lost
and he happens to live in this state
where the records of that culture were
preserved
and he thinks the problem with his
contemporaries
is they've lost the way they don't they
don't follow this cultural way anymore
and the solution is lifelong training
and ritual and music and poetry
and the idea is you reshape yourself
the goal is to reach you away
but it's going to be a take it's going
to take you a lifetime to do that so
confucius didn't get there until age 70.
he's got this autobiography where he
says you know what when i age 15 i set
my heart on learning and then i learned
ritual and then and then at age 70
he says i could follow my heart's desire
without transgressing the bounds so
that's when he's reached a state of a
way and it sounds like enlightenment in
some sense
yes but it's not
um
yeah i wouldn't put it that way exactly
it's a state where you're basically
you've reshaped your system one so
thoroughly
that it just accords with this external
normative culture okay perfectly in a
way that you don't have to think about
you can now run on autopilot um and
you'll be you'll do everything the right
way
um so that's roughly the the kind of
classical confusion position there's a
confucian named menchus
who tries to so let me tell you about
the taoist first and there's someone who
kind of tries to split the difference so
the taoists on the other hand say
if you want to be spontaneous
and natural and
culture is deadly and training is deadly
so you need to so the first of these
figures laozi
thinks that
the reason everyone agrees that
everything sucks right now
they're in the warring states everyone's
fighting with each other literally
right yeah
or you know it's it's a standard thing
word the current world is terrible right
um they all think we can get back to
some golden age that used to exist for
laozi we do that by getting rid of
culture so he thinks that learning and
trying
are the enemy
and that if you become a confusion and
you train in the rituals and you learn
the classics you're just going to become
a hypocrite
you'll be able to go through the motions
but you'll you won't be genuinely
virtuous
and so i call him he's a primitivist he
wants us to get back to
the supposedly natural lifestyle of
living in small-scale communities
low-tech
in the trade book i described them as
the warring states hippies they're
basically yeah it's a lot like the
counter culture movement in the 60s
let's get back to nature
get rid of technology warfare is bad
it's all caused by consumerism and greed
um very similar insights in the in the
dodging
um then the second of the so-called
taoists they weren't a self-recognized
school but it's a helpful label is this
guy juan's
and he similar he thinks like laozi that
trying's bad training and culture can
mess you up
but he assumes this has all already
happened to us
and what we have to do is learn how to
not he thinks that escaping to a
primitive utopia
is an example of trying
that actually
by doing that we're falling into the
trap of thinking that we can make
ourselves good
and so he thinks what we need to do is
just make our minds empty
so that we can respond to reality
as it really is in front of us he thinks
normally
we're using our mind and categories
and so we're not seeing the world we're
seeing linguistic categories
projected onto the world
but if we can get beyond language and
concepts he thinks we can actually
perceive the world directly
and when we can do that we'll respond
perfectly we'll be free of hang-ups
we'll be free of all the consumerism and
stuff that laozi was worried about but
we do it not by setting up a new type of
community we're going to do it
so that zhuangzi and sage doesn't
necessarily look from the outside any
different from a confusion okay they're
doing confucius stuff
but they've now internally kind of
changed their attitude toward the world
and that's what makes them free so
that's that's his goal
and then in between is this guy menchus
who um
thinks that we have the beginnings of
virtue in us or our
our nature is potentially good so all
the confucian virtues he thinks don't
come from the joe dynasty he thinks they
come from inside of us mentis thinks we
have all the confusion virtues in an
incipient form inside of us
and all we need to do is cult is help
them grow
so he uses his agricultural metaphors so
we're trying to kind of strengthen our
sprouts he calls them sprouts and we're
trying to strengthen them and grow them
into true virtues and so we need to try
but not too hard because we don't want
to be like the farmer from song who
pulled on his sprouts because he was
impatient they weren't growing fast
enough so he went out pulled on them and
pulled them out of the ground
it was a mistake as an agriculturalist
so um so he kind of is splitting the
difference and then we also have um some
consequentialists some hardcore
system two only consequentialists who
think that all this virtue ethics stuff
is is dangerous and sloppy
and what we need is a systematic way to
determine what's right and wrong
by measuring consequences and then we
can do the right thing
and then we have some legalists too
these people who who really were
interested in just ordering the state
who believed the key was you know harsh
legal codes enforced consistently
following rules i love the idea that the
name legalism would be a good marketing
ploy like that just doesn't sound like a
philosophy that anyone is going to
clamor to get behind yeah
the school the school of regulations
that's essentially what they recall so
yeah yeah can we talk a little bit about
so it's a very complex time yeah no
clearly and i i was it's also very early
time so i was going to ask just briefly
about the historicity of all these folks
whose names we are dropping i mean i'm
pretty sure mencius existed i'm less
clear about the others uh i mean what do
we know about them and and could you
possibly relate that very charming story
of how lauta actually wrote his book
yeah so the the probably the least
historical i would say is laozi so his
name literally means the old master
so if you're gonna write a book and put
a name on it that would make people read
it that's what you would do
um you know the old wise guy wrote this
so
um
so the standard story is you know he was
a historical figure and he studied
ritual with confucius but then realized
it was wrong and
um
decided to go off and write this book or
he decided to go off and be just be in
touch with the dao
and then the historic the the
traditional story is he was going to
india he decided to leave china because
china was so messed up
and
on on his way out
a border official said to him i won't
let you leave until you write down your
teachings
and so this is why we have the book
because you know laotz is very reluctant
to use words but he was forced to by
this border official and that's why we
have the dota record of his writings um
and then off of the story goes on that
he went to india
he became the buddha
oh good and that's why when buddhism
came into china around the beginning of
the common era
it looked a lot like taoism and the
chinese explanation was well of course
because we embedded it and
exported it to india
so yeah so that's almost certainly not
true i think the the dow de jing book
the loud sub book was probably put
together
um
by a community of these primitivists
and we we have we have hints of them in
the end of the analytics the the
writings of the teachings of confucius
we have these interesting encounters at
the end of the analytics where
um confucius is running into these
people who are
living primitive lifestyles and actually
absurdly primitive lifestyles like
they're not using technologies that
exist
they're self-consciously you know like
one example is that someone's pulling a
plow by themselves
and they had oxygen yeah like that's
what a normal farmer would be using and
then when confucius stops and questions
them they quote from the odes this
classical book of poetry
and they know who confucius is so these
are clearly not normal farmers they're
they're educated elites
who have dropped out and gone back to
the countryside and withdrawn from
society um
are we pretty sure that confucius
existed as a person and wrote the things
that we think he wrote
his book so the analytics that is the
record of his teachings is not written
by him it's really just a it's a
collection of teachings so it's um
encounters between him and disciples or
stories about things he did
um he probably existed and i think that
um the at least the first half of the
the analytics this book we have books
one through ten
is probably early whirring states and
does a pretty good job of
recording his teachings i mean both
soccer teams right
both socrates and jesus did a pretty
good job of being influential despite
never writing anything down right if you
get the right
rules very similar to them right so it's
it's records of these supposed teachings
okay but then some of these other texts
like the uh the menchus you know
certainly the shenzhou which is a late
warring states confusion text um were
written by individuals who okay probably
really existed there's even a legend of
a story that lauta and confucius met at
one point right
yeah so supposedly there's a one legend
is that loud so uh or confucius was
studying ritual with laozi as one
version or loud suicide ritual with
confucius and then realized that this
was the wrong way to do it there's all
sorts of myths that arose around these
figures um and it's it's even more
complicated because confucius also pops
up
and lots of early texts
delivering he pops into a scene and
delivers some teachings and then leaves
and you know was that confucius
really did he really say that so there's
lots of stories built up around them
that are almost certainly not
historically super accurate
we can't do everything we want to from
home but one thing we can do is exercise
with peloton you'll have a workout
experience like no other without ever
leaving home one of my favorite aspects
of peloton is not only that you have
bike classes where you're cycling your
heart out but there are full body
workouts you get on and off of the bike
with themes from cardio strength yoga
pilates and more one of the greatest and
most obvious things about peloton is the
curated music selection they have epic
artist collaborations and instructor
curated playlists so the music
experience is unlike any other whether
you're in the mood for hip hop pop or
country the peloton bike has the right
music to keep you entertained and
motivated all year long with the peloton
bike there's nothing like working out
from home learn more at
onepeloton.com new members can try
peloton classes free for 30 days at one
peloton.com
app terms apply that's o n e p e l o t o
n dot com
and it's is it's kind of amazing at
least to me but maybe i don't know a
common causal uh force going on here but
these people are working at roughly the
same time as plato and aristotle and
their friends in ancient greece right uh
he's very far apart by ancient world
standards but the time to invent huge
new philosophical school of thoughts was
clearly then yeah so there's this
interesting it's not just ancient greece
and china it's also when zarasper was
teaching
it's probably around the period of the
historical buddha
when some of these early
schools of indian thought were getting
going and so there was this german
thinker named carl jaspers who was very
impressed by this and came up with this
idea of the axial age
that it was around this time that
i mean he had a very kind of hegelian
metaphysical
story about this it's like when the
human geist the human spirit became
self-conscious finally you know we were
kind of grinding along as animals and
then we kind of woke up
um so
his his
metaphysical story is probably false but
there is something to this idea of an
axial age
and i think it probably has to do with
just um cult you know agriculture
gets started and spreads around the
world um not exactly at the same time
but it really starts to ramp up around
the same time
and once you get enough wealth and
complexity
you start to have people whose jobs can
be
like ours right you know to sit around
and think and roll drugs yeah yeah
and so i think it's really just a
function of around the same time
you got enough uh excess wealth that it
could support
parasites like us who aren't actually
doing useful productive work but we're
thinking about stuff and right and
writing that stuff down right right yeah
i know exactly so
let me just uh focus in so our audience
and and me uh have a as clear a picture
of possible what's going on with the
different schools so confucianism i
think kind of makes sense to the western
mind even if not a lot of westerners uh
become confucianists in their old age
but the idea that
uh
there are rituals and ceremonies and our
social role is cr
very important and
um you know learning is important and
things like that that's this is virtue
is is a way of acting in the world with
other people right i mean these are all
there's appropriate social roles these
are all sort of confusion ideas yeah
yeah yeah but but taken quite strongly
so
uh at least for confucius
you you can't think without culture so
he really thinks culture is forming the
basis of your thought
which i find my students really
struggle with sometimes because they
tend to think
that they think of things on their own
like oh i had these great ideas and this
is where i think confucianism is a
corrective to some kind of
modern western views of the self so so
where the confucian view is
contradicting i think our standard
modern western view of the self
is he's he's dubious about the power of
reason
unguided by culture
he's he's uh
dubious about the power of individual
creativity he doesn't think that people
really come up with something completely
new they're just kind of reworking older
stuff
which i think is probably true um
he also thinks that you as who you are
as a person
is inextricably bound up with your
social roles
it's not just that you sean are this
fully formed human being and then you
happen to be these other roles as well
who you sean are is structured by those
roles that you play and that you've
played in the past and that you will
play in the future okay and so and so
you you don't really have a meaningful
self outside the context of your social
roles so it's a fairly strong view of
the importance of social roles yeah no
that is a little deeper a little
stronger than i was putting it when i
said you know westerners can understand
it i think that sort of the
questions being asked here uh where what
is our place in society what is our role
vis-a-vis the ancestors and our family
and so forth are questions that we
already value even if the answers are a
little bit different but but what do you
what you're saying if i can sort of say
it back and you can correct me is
that
confucianism is very much against what
we might think of as the enlightenment
individualistic way of looking at the
world that the world is not a collection
of individuals it's something
there's a higher level of emergent
structure that is at least as important
as determining the individuals there's
some downward causation going on there
yeah and and also the other kind of
anti-enlightenment thing part of it is
anti-enlightenment individualism
it's also anti-enlightenment
anti-traditionalism so you know the
enlightenment's all about you know
waking up and not believing something
because the priest told you but figuring
it out under on your own
and you know then the paradigmatic
example of that is descartes right
sitting down by himself in front of a
fire
and doubting everything
demon down to his own existence
and then you know lo and behold from
kojito ergosum he's able to build up the
entire body of human knowledge including
the catholic church he gets the catholic
church back
just through the power of his individual
reason right
um
and confucius would think that's absurd
that we're we're in the same way that
your social role was really deeply
shaping who you are as a person
tradition shapes the way you think and
the idea that you could just
be like descartes and independently
reproduce all of that on your own is is
delusional one of the things that is
appealing about descartes project even
if you don't agree with his specific
steps along the way is that he's really
looking for certainty right you know
absolute metaphysical grounding that you
can't argue against once you appreciate
it is it is there some sense in which
either confucianism or chinese
philosophy more generally is a bit more
fallibilistic and a bit more you know uh
we're working towards something rather
than here is the once and for all final
foundation
yeah that's an interesting way to put it
i hadn't thought of it that way
um
confucius thinks that that the western
joe culture
is perfectly good
and captures everything all the truths
of the world so in the in a way
okay he thinks there was a period of
time when people had figured everything
out and there's suggestions that it may
have even been revealed by heaven so it
was a kind of divine revelation of the
system
um
shunza is more you call him more of a
fallibilist i would think in that he
thinks that humans invented the
confucian way okay
and they did it over time
uh they basically there was a series of
these kind of cultural geniuses
who cobbled together the confucian way
for functional purposes
because it helped us live in large-scale
societies and be harmonious and and um
he's got an interesting uh description
of the state of nature that looks a lot
like hobbs where he says you know human
desires are limitless
resources are limited
and so that's a recipe for disaster so
how do we deal with that we've got to
learn how to restrain desires and
reshape them
and the confucian way is the perfect way
to do that
so he thinks it's actually a kind of
artifact that was constructed by people
over a period of time
he thinks it perfect it works perfectly
so he's also like yeah the confusion is
the only way to be
but in his model there's some openness
to change right so if the environment
changed conditions changed
new sage kings could arise who would
innovate and kind of fix the confusion
way so it would fit the new structure
whose view are we giving now
this is shinzo so
x-u-n-z-i opinion and he's the he's the
end of the whirring states
confucian who believes he's the true
inheritor of confucius himself
and who thinks that menchus is kind of a
pseudo-taoist
poser
and he's probably eddie's right i think
am i am i right in putting them in the
slots of ventius was uh
emphasizing the intrinsic good of human
beings and
was the other person's name
emphasizing that they're flawed in
various ways and we had to fix that
they're bad they're bad so i mean the
famous the slogans that go with the two
of them is with uh mench's shinshon
human nature is good
and and then shunza wrote a chapter
called
human nature is bad
and fair enough you know and his i think
shinzo's formulations truer to the
original confucian vision okay that
humans don't basically humans don't have
internal moral resources
we're not born with any kind of
intuitions that would lead us to
morality we have to learn morality from
the outside from tradition and our
teachers and texts that we inherit and
he would have said that then mencius is
just a taoist in confucian clothing
yeah okay
and uh
if i think about the taoists then
it seems very roughly that as opposed to
the confusion focus on society and
people and relations the taoists are
much more focused on nature and
i don't want to say individualism but at
least you know your personal
uh way of going through the world yeah
yeah so so with laozi
it seems like he's the social unit is
the family so you kind of go back to
living in these little villages and
maybe you have a family he talks a lot
about the importance of family
but it's natural relations not all this
filial piety that the confucians talk
about
uh zhuangz on the other hand is the
closest to an individualist that you get
in early china okay uh he was probably
influenced by this other philosopher
called
young zhu who we don't uh y-a-n-g and
then his last name is zhu
we don't unfortunately we don't know
much about young jew we lost there was a
book that recorded his teachings that we
lost
and so almost everything we know about
him is from his enemies like menchus who
hated him uh but he seems to have been
an individual he he was like you know
the the big the greatest value in the
world is to preserve your own life and
live out your natural lifespan
and to experience pleasure
and
if that means you don't serve as an
official if that means that you don't
engage in public life
so be it you know go off and live in the
woods by yourself
so juan's is much more that style of
individual
individual perfection yeah and he
doesn't seem to have any kind of big
story about how you're going to change
society or live in society and
one thing that we have to at least try
to do um there's a famous saying that
the doubt that cannot be spoken is not
the truth that can be spoken it's not
the true dao but still it'd be nice if
we could explain what this word means a
little bit dao right yeah is it possible
to explain it even though it can't be
said
yeah that's i mean that's the dow da
jing right so they're suspicious of
language they're worried about trying to
get trapped in any kind of linguistic
formulation
the the concept itself is pretty simple
it literally means way
like a road
that's the original meaning of it and it
continues in classical warring states
classical chinese it's still used in
that literal sense
but it comes to mean probably confu the
analects is the first time is used in
this philosophical metaphysical sense
um it's the right way to do something
and it becomes in the analects almost
like a metaphysical
reality like the way the universe is
and
so this is the sense so sometimes heaven
and the way are used interchangeably or
they're used as part of a compound
tiendal
the way of heaven
so um that's the basic meaning of way
it's a it's a it can mean it can also
mean teaching so like confucius will
talk about
um you know my way being manifested in
the world and by that he means his
teaching
okay
and
is it
[Laughter]
to the western ear once again you know
i'm sort of being judgey here of
brilliant people from thousands of years
ago but um when i read about taoism you
know there's some wisdom there clearly
it's very very interesting but part of
me wants to say like it is just hippie
back to nature stuff like what about you
know making the world a better place
what about you know struggling against
things that are bad in the world like
where did where does that come in is
that a is that a valid reaction to have
or am i just missing something deeper in
what they're saying that's a that's a
totally valid reaction to have the i
think the central criticism of say
juansa is he's got no story about
social justice or how you would help the
world
in his defense so if i were to defend
him
he would say
you wanted to you want to make the world
a better place so you you know support
oxfam and you join this political party
that's gonna
make things better
and he would say you're just gonna screw
things up
actually the way you make things better
is by you getting in touch with the dao
okay and then when you do that
you're gonna have this kind of ripple
effect on the people around you
so if you really let's say you suddenly
got into away
or let's say i suddenly got into huawei
so i'm somehow now a taoist sage which i
most certainly am not but
thought experiment
i have i have this powerful duh this
charisma now
you and i talk
and you're uh whatever um effective
altruists you think you're gonna give
away your kidney and do all this great
stuff for the world
but through my power i will make you
realize that that's misguided or you're
gonna just do more harm that way and i'm
going to make you more relaxed and more
in touch with your nature
and so then we're going to get off this
call
and you're going to go interact with
some people and now you're going to be
more relaxed and natural and so you're
going to make them more relaxed and
natural
so you could argue that he's got this
kind of person-to-person very slow
transformation model of how the world's
going to become a better place
and he thinks that if you try to do it
directly and consciously you're almost
certainly going to screw it up you're
going to make it worse
that is helpful i mean i do see that
that's at least a strategy i think
there's an empirical question about
whether it's an effective strategy
whether or not exactly yeah yeah that's
an empirical issue yeah but i mean maybe
it goes into
or at least it's rubbed shoulders with
theories of non-violent resistance or
something like that you know there's
something like that it it
fits with people who are skeptical of
movements
right who are skeptical of large-scale
attempts to um impose a vision of how
the world should be
on the world and am i again in his uh
favor am i right to recall that taoism
actually
gives women and men more or less equal
status unlike almost all the other
schools of thought in any part of the
world at that time
yeah i
i wouldn't go that far would i so so uh
the dao da jing uses
female metaphors of the female
to get across its point so
the dao de jing
says people want to be strong
but really you should value weakness
people want to be bright you should
value darkness
it thinks that in going for these values
you actually end up subverting them and
turning them into their opposite it's
because the solution is to
be weak
but it's a quote-unquote weak right
you're being weak
in the same way that a martial artist
who's doing jiu jitsu is being weak
right they're giving way in order to be
effective
and so in that context they talk about
the male and the female
so everyone values the male but you
should value the female if you're a
taoist
because the female is passive is dark um
is the valley as opposed to you know the
mountains
um
so it's
is that feminism
it's saying that there's you know
essentially something that women are
like and it's weakness but that you know
we could model ourselves on that i'm not
sure i'd call that
like second generation
feminism but but in practice
were there is that in practice were
there female taoist sages or was it
still more or less a guy's club
it was mostly a guy's club but it's hard
to say because men were primarily the
literate ones
we do know that later on when taoism
becomes an organized religion
there are female devotees and
but they're also doing stuff like
once they get into these
physical practices they're doing sexual
practices
for instance where they need to uh have
sex with a string of virgins but
hold their essence in
um and that doesn't seem like super like
uh feminist activity
you know these are elite men who are uh
you know it's always like jeffrey
epstein but uh i presume it was not
female devotees having sex with a string
of male virgins
yeah we don't hear we don't hear about
that don't hear about that side of the
story okay
i think i think it's i think it's
overblown the extent to which they're
friendlier
but inherently they are because they
don't believe in the traditional
hierarchies yeah okay whereas
confucianism believes that you know the
male female
distinction is part of the structure of
the universe basically
men are in public life women are in
private life that's the way it should be
well and in fact um
i gave that was a little bit of a hard
time for being quietest about social
justice but presumably confucianism is
just as
uh
vulnerable to that kind of criticism
yeah and you know
they're not as bad as aristotle you can
give them that so for you know for
aristotle women and slaves were just not
really fully human right
uh
confucian women they're not
supposed to be in public life but
they're definitely fully human and one
so people who have been trying to
emphasize you know maybe we got the
beginnings of some feminism we can
retrieve out of confucianism
point out that women do appear
in stories
where they're
basically men are doing something wrong
they're not being they're not living up
to the confusion way
and the mom or the wife
pops in and quotes from the odes and
says you're not doing the right thing
and the man is shamed and does the right
thing
and she goes back to the
house
so she's not doing anything herself but
at least
women if not
active moral agents in the world
can reason morally in the same way men
can
so that's something
when hiring gets hard you need indeed
the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple just attract interview
and hire with indeed you can do all your
hiring in one place including the
interviewing so you don't just hope that
the perfect candidate will find you
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter indeed instant match provides a
list of quality candidates whose resumes
are on indeed the moment you post a
sponsor job and with indeed assessments
you can choose from 135 skills tests to
help make sure you're finding
applications from people with the skills
you need according to talent nest indeed
delivers four times more hires than all
other job sites combined so get started
right now for a seventy five dollar
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape indeed.com mindscape offer
valid through september 30th terms and
conditions apply
i mean you said something very briefly
there that is worth teasing out when
taoism turned more into a religion uh my
impression is again correct me if i'm
wrong is that these really were
philosophical schools to start in the
similar way as plato and aristotle would
have been but plato and aristotle didn't
turn into religions as far as i know but
in some sense confucianism and daoism
did and buddhism of course
yeah i'm a little worried i yeah maybe
it was speaking loosely when i said that
i really should have said when it turned
into a popular religious practice
um i think that the
these early schools of thought are
religious i think that all pre-modern
philosophy is religious if you look at
plato or aristotle
they have religious world views and
they're formulating their ethics in
terms of these religious world views i
think this distinction between
philosophy and religion
is a product of the enlightenment it's a
relatively recent development you know
it's an enlightenment conceit
that we could talk about values
in a way that's completely divorced from
ontological or metaphysical commitments
yeah
and so i'm a little leery of talking
about philosophy versus religion in that
sense but it's definitely the case that
these were these were
very philosophically oriented religious
movements
and and some of them like taoism became
these more technical
practices that were aimed at things like
uh
immortality personal immortality and
things like that or controlling the
world in various ways well i guess to me
that does sound like a question that is
legitimate to ask even if the
distinction between philosophy and
religion was not so much of a
distinction back in the day
um what was their metaphysics and
ontology were they uh to what extent
were they naturalist versus theist i
mean they talk about heaven and god all
the time but
it's never clear whether it's just part
of a story and a metaphor or whether
it's you know more or less uh as real as
a
monotheistic western god would be
i i think that confucius the historical
confucius when he talks about heaven
it's pretty full-blooded anthropomorphic
being
heaven gets angry heaven can abandon him
he actually complains at one point
because heaven seems to have abandoned
him good
i think it's a pretty full-blooded
anthropomorphic being
when you get to the end of the whirring
states
and a thinker like juan's the heaven
becomes just this kind of force it
doesn't really have
a personality anymore
and then when you get to shenzhen i
think is at least that i know of he's
the first i'd argue the first atheistic
thinker and you could argue that his
system is maybe philosophical and not
religious in the sense that
he's not relying on any kind of
metaphysical
justification for he really thinks that
uh the confucian way
was created by humans for humans
to
uh and he's a virtue ethicist but his
his
just meta justification for the
confucian way is kind of utilitarian
he's like we have a state of nature we
got to figure out how to make it work
confucianism does that the best in the
most efficient way
um
so he arguably
is the closest to an atheistic
philosopher we have in the warring
states
interesting okay yeah i think that that
is a fact that i used to know and then
forgot i think i might even have
mentioned it in my book the big picture
now that you're saying all those words
it's sort of coming back to me because i
was looking into the history of
naturalism there are various moments
when it sort of came and then kind of
got got crushed a little bit but um yeah
he never it never took off yeah but it's
interesting because he still advocates
for religious practice
because he's got he's got this very
durkheimian view of how of the function
of ritual so he
there's a famous passage where he says
um
uh we do the rain prayer
and
what happens it's going to rain or it's
not going to rain doing the rain prayer
doesn't affect the rain at all
um so should we get rid of the rain
prayer
absolutely not we should keep doing it
that's right so why do we do it
because it brings people together
um
everyone sits in their
hierarchical place and so they get a
visual representation of where they sit
in the social hierarchy
they reaffirm their commitment to the
ruler and to the way
so he's got this functional story about
religious ritual where he wants he wants
people to keep doing it
but he says the the common person is
going to continue to think that we're
doing it to make it rain
the gentleman his peers his educated
peers know that we're
it's going to rain or it's not going to
rain there's no has no efficacy
except social we're doing it for these
social reasons so he's got this really
interesting functional role i kind of
like that but it also makes me think
that we've not made any progress in the
last 2 500 years
and you're like yeah students already
said that
something has become clear in many of
the examples you've given is a stylistic
difference that maybe i'm perceiving
correctly or incorrectly between
the chinese and the greeks
in this era namely like they were the
the chinese
well so let me let me back up to mention
um
the only one of these texts i've
actually been uh exposed to directly is
the zhuangza which is through the
cartoon book that you wrote the uh
preface for why don't you mention that
because everyone should read these books
yeah that's a great that cartoon is
great
and is it the and there's a series of
them right
yeah yeah he did all the classics in
cartoon form
that is so when i lived in taiwan i read
these in chinese um and i remember
thinking oh when i get back to the
states i want to translate these
and brian bruya my colleague beat me to
it so i just wrote the preference to his
cartoon but he did a really he did a
really nice job what was the cartoonist
name again
uh uh what's his his surname's tsai i'm
trying to remember his given name now
i'll look it up for the show notes but
um yeah prince princeton university
press has put out the juanzo one but
anyway the uh the point being that it's
full of stories and metaphors and
parables or whatever you want to call it
in a in a more literary vein than i
would think of aristotle talking of
course plato did his dialogues but
usually those were just excuses for the
characters to give kind of speeches
extended speeches yeah we're not very
metaphorical sometimes he had the
metaphors in there um is this you know
can we think about the differences
between ancient chinese philosophy and
ancient greek philosophies is that a
legitimate difference between them and
how meaningful is that difference
i wouldn't exaggerate the meaningfulness
of it so i've spent some portion of my
career arguing against this view of
china being metaphorical and kind of
holistic and thinking in images
and greek based western culture being
analytic and abstract and um it's humans
are humans we all think in metaphors i
mean i've spent a chunk of my career
doing cognitive linguistic stuff you
know kind of lake of johnson and
blending theory so humans think in
images that's how we think um
i think a legitimate way to put it would
be
[Music]
western philosophers were not super
comfortable with that like they had this
idea
that we could get away from images and
actually really figure things out
literally in an abstract way
and that that should be the goal of
philosophy we should come up with an
abstract
representation of reality that would be
to the extent possible stripped of
metaphor
and that would actually be a literal
representation of the world
whereas the confusions and and i think
this is true of early chinese thinkers
in general uh were more pragmatic
they thought the goal of philosophy was
to get people to live well
and to make society function well
and you used whatever tools necessary to
make that happen they weren't really so
um if you want to think of it in terms
of gilbert rile's distinction between
knowing that versus knowing how
right um
there's there is a sense in which
chinese philosophy valued know-how
and ability to live well
and they prize that over abstract
accounts of the world
yeah i mean that's very good i'm glad
you said that because that is the
impression i got so it's not completely
fake and as you say it's probably
matters of degree rather than completely
absolutely no because you have western
thinkers right who were i mean aristotle
was about know-how right he was training
you to
be a virtuous person and a you know
phronesis practical reason
can't be
codified you just have it or you don't
so it is a it's a classic kind of
know-how
with all those warnings in place if i
were to take this distinction and run
with it further than probably i should
um
i mean i can't help but come at this
from the point of view of a theoretical
physicist who does all of those things
you said the greeks wanted us to do
inventing abstract representations of
the world um is it possible that that
sort of greek predilection
paved the way
for uh an abstract scientific view of
the world and helped science catch on in
that way but maybe at the same time it
is not as good at living as human beings
in the world along the way
yeah that's possible there's been loads
of books over the decades on this right
the greek origins of science and
you know for a long time it was a big
cottage industry trying to just explain
why science didn't arise in china
because they were technologically
way more advanced in the west for a very
long time um so what what was going
wrong what was going wrong there
assuming that science was what we were
shooting for as a
so yeah there's something to that um
there's something to the valuing of
abstract thought um
i think individualism also plays a role
so um
but then i think a lot of just
historical accidents are are playing an
important role so
when science gets started in europe
europe's fragmented between all these
different states and different rulers
and if you said something that the
catholic church didn't likes you just go
to next door to the protestant rulers
place and you hang out there
so there was ability and you know
arguably this was the result of
geographical fragmentation the fact that
europe is just kind of chopped up you
know it's got the mediterranean and the
south and it's
broken up by mountains
um northern china so the
classic cradle of chinese civilization
the yellow river valley
is organized around this river it kind
of
is more like egypt if you want to think
of it that way so
you get
large-scale agriculture happening on a
massive scale very early
um whereas if you look at greece so
david keatley who's a uh
famous uh he's passed away about a
decade ago
scholar of early china contrasted greece
and china and he argued
one of the differences is this focus on
the individual versus the group so you
look at greek
you look at greek pottery
it's portrayals of heroes so this
piece of pottery has achilles he's
recognizably achilles and he's doing
this famous thing that achilles did
whereas you'll get china and it's
anonymous figures performing music or
doing ritual it's a group scene
and he traces that back to the fact that
greece you know greece sucks for
agriculture you can't get any kind of
decent large-scale agriculture off the
ground so it's it's fisher you know
people fishing or herding goats growing
small patches of vegetables it's broken
up
they're trading they're traveling around
they're more individualistic
china at a very early stage has rice
agriculture
and in the in the north where they're
not growing rice they it's very dry and
so they're having to irrigate so even if
they're not growing a labor-intensive
crop like rice so rice is super labor
intensive you've got to flood the fields
and you need really elaborate group
cooperation to do that and even in the
north because of the nature of the
climate they needed a large scale water
water control
irrigation flood control and things like
that and so the argument is the chinese
state got centralized very early on and
economically and agriculturally it got
organized around
group activities very early on
that tended to favor the group over
individuals
and this may have had something to do
with why there's rel you see relatively
more individualism
in in the west um
but even in china there's a really
interesting science article from i want
to say like eight years ago
tell him the lead author where he looked
at um
rice versus grain
county producing counties in china and
looking at them really
they're close together so he's
controlling for almost everything except
for the style of agriculture that they
have
and on that whole these holistic versus
analytic thinking tasks that
psychologists use
people from rice growing regions are
much more holistic and people from the
smaller scale wheat growing regions are
more analytic
so even within these societies you know
if your style of life is slightly
different you're going to probably
think about the individual's
relationship to the group slightly
differently it is i mean it's a
combination of
irresistible set of ideas and and heart
there's a net you have to resist pushing
them too far right we had joe henry on
the show he talked about the weirdness
of the west and so forth and i love it
and that but you know it's just it's
it's too good in some sense to be
completely true so understanding the
limitations of the of this uh these
connections is just as important and so
in that vein um there are examples of
the ancient chinese thinkers
doing what we might think of as you know
metaphysics or uh abstract thinking and
maybe you can tell the audience who
doesn't know juan's favor famous
butterfly dream story which has to do
with the mind body problem yeah
well i think it's more about skepticism
okay so it's you know he he says i had a
dream that i was a butterfly i was
flying around i was happy and i was
wonderful and then i woke up and i
thought oh i just dreamt that i was a
butterfly
but how do i know that i'm not actually
really of that butterfly and i'm just
now dreaming that i'm drongza and you
know which is the dream and which is
reality um
he's trying i think the purpose of that
story is he's trying to shake up our
our confidence that we know what's going
on
that
and in this particular case i think what
he's he's targeting is our fear of death
so you know right now we're living we
think when we die it's going to be
horrible but how do we know we don't
know what's going to happen
um so he's he is cult he wants to
cultivate um epistemically a kind of
humbleness
and that's he's using that skeptical
argument as a way to get us to think oh
maybe we don't really know
what the right way to be is it it is
certainly stark contrast with descartes
right i mean descartes does this
skeptical exercise and says now i will
rebuild everything on a completely firm
basis thing juan's it basically says
deal with it
who knows rightly this is how the world
is we don't know it could be demons
fooling us everything could be demons
all the way down right we just don't
know
um
but it's a third i think it's uh you
know dwanzo uses metaphysics he uses
logic sometimes
but in a way that deconstructs logic he
probably was trained as a logician so i
actually didn't mention another school
of early chinese thought which were the
logicians so these were people who
really thought
you could capture
the structure of reality
in words so
you know words were categories that map
on to distinct groups of objects in the
world
and then you could if you could come up
with a
completely logical and accurate way of
constructing
sentences with these terms you could
have an abstract account of reality and
an abstract account of how to act in the
right way
this was going on in china yeah so there
were logical positivists long before we
had any they were logical positivists um
and they never took off um so it's
interesting that juan su was probably
trained as one of these people because
he uses this is not always picked up by
translators but he's often using terms
in a technical logical sense not in the
standard way the words are used
um so he seems to have been trained in
this approach and then abandoned it and
thought that it wasn't the way to live
properly and when you say technological
sense i mean um
not technological technical logical
sense uh
is that what we think of as you know
syllogisms deductions inductive kind of
reasoning
yeah something very much like that okay
um and using terms like uh this word
ching
q-i-n-g and pinyin
which means emotion typically in in
classical chinese at this time
but in most logic it refers to the
categorical essence of something
so the the ching of something
is the quality that distinguishes that
category from other similar categories
got it okay
it's the distinctive property of that
category and if you don't understand
that some passages in the drawings that
don't make sense or sounds like he's a
bad philosopher but you when you
understand he's using these terms in a
technical moa sense it makes more sense
okay let me run by you uh one while one
more wild generalization that you can
go ahead
because you've already said that you
know
there is this axial age kind of idea
that uh humanity reached a stage where
parasites like you and i could be
supported by society and so they could
have people whose job it was to think
these big ideas and write them down and
so forth so in some sense there's a sort
of right place right time aspect to
these people right like they could be
first like they could put ideas out
there and then there's fewer
gigantic new philosophical schools
coming later on because in some sense
they're reflections or modifications of
the previous ones so here's my crazy
idea you know if i look at raphael's
picture the school of athens um
he has plato and he's pointing to the
sky and he has aristotle pointing to the
earth and in some sense this is supposed
to represent this big dichotomy between
thinking and pure rationality you know
plato and the forms and so forth and
aristotle more empirical evidence-based
uh experience of the world and sort of
that was the big division between the
schools of thought whereas it seems to
me that in the
chinese thinking uh again to hugely over
generalize we have this
dichotomy between the confucianists
thinking about society and people and
our roles and the was thinking about
nature and ourselves and where we put in
it and that's the distinction that was
that was driven there is it is it
completely overreaching to think that
these
choices of what distinctions to
highlight early on played a huge role in
how people thought then for the next
2000 years
that's reasonable another way to put it
is trying versus not trying
so confronted with the same paradox they
break different ways so the confusion
say yeah it's paradox but keep trying
and it'll sort itself out
you'll eventually become like confucius
just trust us do this for a long time
and you'll you'll become way eventually
whereas the taoists are much more
worried about the problem of of effort
contaminating the end state and they
really are kind of allergic to
trying
and i argue in my dissertation that this
dichotomy between trying and not trying
explains a lot of the divisions that
happen later in chinese philosophy slash
religion okay um you constantly have
you know and what's interesting is that
sometimes the the debate gets solved by
doctrinal fiat
so
um when the neoconfusions
come in this is in like the
12th century a.d
um they say mentions is right
human is good
you know not trying is the right way to
do it because we have this good nature
no one's it's wrong to say otherwise
um as soon as you get that you get
people who are like yeah
well it's good but
as soon as we're born it gets
contaminated and so how do we fix that
oh we study the classics and we do
ritual and we rely so i sometimes call
this internalism versus externalism but
it's a real tension or trying not trying
but basically
where's where's the source of morality
you've got
one side that thinks it comes from cult
it comes from the outside it comes from
culture or tradition or other people
teachers
comes from authority they tend to be
more culturally conservative
on the other side you have these you
could argue liberals who think that it
comes from the inside we have a good
nature all we have to do is look inside
and be authentic and everything will be
all right um and that that liberal
versus conservative divide or
internalist versus externalist or trying
versus not trying is this common fault
line you see okay
in chinese thought it appears again and
again and i can't help but i know we
touched on this already but it seems to
me that it would be very difficult to be
a good taoist and a good theoretical
physicist because uh it's not just gonna
happen you're not just gonna like you
know relax into coming up with the right
model of dark matter or something like
that you really it seems to me like you
really have to try am i am i missing a
nuance there
yeah yeah but one way to to
solve that problem or at least
contextualize it i think taoism is best
understood as a reaction to confucianism
rather than a coherent model in itself
so understood that way
you have to get trained in theoretical
physics you have to do a lot of trying
but if you want to have a really genuine
new insight into theoretical physics you
need to stop trying got it and you need
to be more like the taoist so so that's
the way i've always understood them is
as a
you can't have just complete not trying
it's not how humans work yeah but if you
see the dallas position as a corrective
to the excesses of trying or the
excesses of relying on the prefrontal
cortex or on tradition or on writing or
logic
it starts to make it starts to be more
plausible okay that is actually uh very
plausible i mean to be a good
theoretical physicist even you know
requires a little bit of uh
being so into it that ideas come to you
there's no algorithm for finding the
ideas right yeah it's not mysterious and
and so maybe that's a good you know sort
of final point to make as we wrap up
here bringing it back to the present day
um
since we've done good all of chinese
thought in an
hour let's do all of modern neuroscience
and psychology in in five minutes and
you can tell me um
you know is is this all just of
historical interest or clearly you've
already told me the answer but but maybe
to illustrate how does this uh fit in
with more modern ideas about how the
brain works or how psychology works what
can what can we the individualistic
hedonistic epicurean uh modern western
person uh take away from these
ideas yeah so that's that's basically
what i explore in trying not to try so
that's i'm taking the
the history and the stuff i did as an
academically
and marrying it with my new interest so
i've spent the last 15 years or so
hanging out with cognitive scientists
social psychologists neuroscientists
and marrying these two together so
one thing you can take away is just
the the importance of spontaneity the
fact that
trying is just the case and and i think
modern psychology has come to this on
its own
that certain goals can't be obtained
through direct driving
there's a lot of things you can obtain
like learning
math and doing other things um but if
you want to be
funny
or if you want to be happy or you want
to be in love or you want to love
something
for its own sake
that can't be forced and and in fact
the forcing
actively prevents you from getting it
so one takeaway that i think is useful
is is at least focusing our attention on
the because i think we as a society
again and it's partly the fault of
descartes and khan and all these these
enlightenment thinkers
is we have this emphasis on striving and
we think that the key to success is
always trying harder and if we didn't
get it right we just gotta try harder um
that's not true there's a lot of things
that actually the the right strategy is
to back off
and relax
and and we understand now cognitively
why that's the case um so there's a lot
of tasks that you can only solve like
lateral thinking tasks if you want to
think of like the rit the remote
associates test
you can't solve that by powering through
with an algorithm you need to just relax
and have the answer pop into your head
we now know that that these kind of
creative insights happen when
the pfc
just shuts down for a bit and chills out
and lets the parts of the brain that
don't normally communicate communicate
with one another
so
that's one insight
another insight is just that it is
genuinely a paradox to try not to try
we face it in our lives all the time and
trying to relax for a job interview
trying to fall asleep if you have
insomnia you know if you're worried
about something and you're thinking and
you know you need to shut your brain
down
and i think because we don't have words
for things like way or duh we don't
notice them as much you know words are
helpful for picking out knowing having
the word schadenfloyd
helps you to recognize an emotion that
you've definitely experienced but until
the germans taught you how much how
enjoyable it is to see the suffering of
others you didn't have a word for it um
and having a word for it helps you
notice it and so i think having words
like way
or at least having the concept at our
disposal
helps us to recognize situations where
spontaneity is what we need
and trying is not going to be helpful
and is it okay to have a glass of wine
along the way does that does that help
that segues very nicely into the latest
project no i mean that's so a glass of
wine is a is just a chemical means for
uh short-circuiting that that tension um
and and and you know in moderate doses
is really helpful for that
and doses are not always moderate and
for news about that people can buy your
your latest book
which we encourage them to do so edward
slingerland thanks so much for being the
weinstein podcast
thanks for having me it's a lot of fun
[Music]
you